a major winter storm is hammering the
southwestern part of the country with
tens of millions of people feeling the
impact warnings or advisories are in
effect for nearly all of Arizona in
parts of Utah New Mexico Nevada and
Southern California
northern Arizona is expected to get hit
the hardest with some areas seeing as
much as three feet of snow Carter Evans
is in Flagstaff Arizona Carter good
morning good morning the flakes began to
fall here around 11 o'clock last night I
think we got about six inches on the
ground so far and that is on top of the
16 inches they got last weekend when
it's all said and done we're expecting
up to two feet of snow in this area now
Flagstaff normally gets a fair amount of
snow but to put this all into
perspective the town of Payson Arizona
it's about 60 miles south of here well
normally they get up just under two feet
per season this storm will likely drop
between two and three feet over the next
48 hours
now while Arizona is ground zero for
this storm take a look at this that is
snow on the Las Vegas Strip it is the
second time in a week for an area that
hasn't seen a measurable amount for a
decade now it's been unusually snowy in
the West these satellite images of the
mountains in California show just how
much more snow cover there is this month
compared to the same time last year the
storm is heading east this weekend it
could bring up to a foot of snow to
areas like Kansas Wisconsin and Iowa and
here in Arizona
well it's going to be 30 to 40 degrees
below normal
gale Wow hang in there Carter evidence
yeah let it snow